nicole how are we doing i dated somebody
briefly for about two months
i got pregnant i told him very early on
when i was about two weeks along
and his response was i had to get an
abortion there was no other option
and i initially considered it
out of fear for about one or two days um
and i had asked him for support and he
just said you know you have my support
and it's to get an abortion so i knew
and so i decided not to get one and i'm
now five months pregnant
and i don't know if i should tell him
now or tell him after the baby is born
i really don't know how to approach this
so
number one i'm i want to applaud you for
following your heart on this one and i
want to applaud you for
doing the hardest thing possible
thank you you can have a girl or a boy
i'm having a girl have you already
thought of a name
um i thought of a million names very
cool
my wife says you can't name something
somebody until you see it
see them so um
we'll see so i won't you don't have to
disclose the name on the air here
um so here's my thought i think he's got
a right to know
okay i think he needs to know that he's
about to be a dad because he's got some
responsibilities
he's got some financial responsibilities
he's got some or he needs to sign all
that stuff away
through official channels but i do
believe that
he has a right to know that he's got a
baby coming into the world
that baby has a right to know that he's
got a mom
and a dad even if they're not together
that baby needs the love of both of
those parents
and so i think there's there's um that's
the right thing to do
is this guy gonna be an idiot in
though temper tantrum and be unsafe or
is he going to be all in
what what is your opinion what do you
think he's going to do i really have no
idea
i really thought he was a great guy he's
a great father to his other two children
and this is just not in his life plan
and i think he's just been very selfish
but this was really a surprise to me
that he reacted this way so i don't feel
like i
i can read his response to this okay and
i'm obviously very deeply hurt by this
so i don't want
my feelings to get in the mix of this
and make things matters worse i really
want to have a good co-parenting
relationship so i guess
i'm just really nervous about bringing
this up with him but
you all are still together are you no no
we pretty much broke up at that point
when he told me to get an abortion
so you all just hooked up for a few
weeks essentially and then you got
pregnant
this year it was about two months of
dating okay
okay yeah i would set up a coffee with
him
please for all for the love
of 2021 all 2021 is depending on you not
doing this one thing okay
okay nicole don't text him this stuff
okay don't email him this stuff have a
meeting with him
in a restaurant in person and obviously
he'll see you and he'll know right away
right well i don't know if you're
showing in five months i'm looking
i don't know not yet okay
we'll let him know that you're gonna be
a dad and you decided to keep the baby
and that just what you told me you've
seen him be a great father
you've seen him be plugged in with his
own kids and you
were hurt by his initial response his
initial
demands if you will but you're keeping
this baby you want to co-parent with him
you want him in this baby's life
and that you need him to step up and do
the right thing
because he's having a baby whether he
wants to or not
okay do you feel at peace with that do
you feel
you feel good with that response yeah
i've
you know i typically trust my own
intuition and i was really torn on this
one as to whether or not i should just
lay low
and let him find out i really didn't
know how to approach this one so i
really appreciate you
um taking my question oh you bet i
appreciate you
better is this your first is this your
first baby
no i'm a single parent to an
eight-year-old so that was
my initial fear is you know raising
another kid as a single parent
and that's why i initially considered
abortion even though it was against my
beliefs
but i knew i just couldn't make that
decision out of fear
good deal have have you told your
eight-year-old
yeah she's very excited very cool so i'm
gonna give you one hint about your
eight-year-old that a counseling
professor
uh mentor of mine passed along and it
was magic in my house
okay this comes from dr aretha marbley
who's one of the smartest minds i've
ever
been able to um learn from and she said
start referring to
the unborn baby as
her baby to your eight-year-old sister
okay
okay so or say your baby
is really or your little sister is
really gonna love meeting you
your little sister is gonna need a lot
of support
i your mommy i'm gonna need you to step
up big because
your little sister this baby we're
having
and what that language does is kids are
desperate for ownership they're
desperate for
participation and they get months
of this apprehension you can put her
hand
on your belly and let her feel it when
she starts kicking all those cool things
but she will begin to take ownership and
you hear a lot about sibling rivalry and
i lost my mom because she had a new baby
and all
in my house i i rolled my eyes and said
all right i'll try it
it was magic it was magic and
my daughter has ended up with the
coolest best big brother you could
imagine
do they fight like morons yes are they
loud and screechy and
yes but i tell you what that that
ownership that my son feels over his
little sister is really something to
behold so it's beautiful
um and so that's that's your that's your
other free advice right you didn't even
call for that one
but yeah dad's got a right to know and
dad needs to have an opportunity to
stand up and do the right thing
and i think by letting him letting him
know
that you believe in him you've seen him
do it once you've seen him do him twice
and that you want to be a great
co-parent with him you want him involved
in this young girl's life
give him the opportunity to do the right
thing
and if not then there may be legal
obligations here
he's but he's got a financial
responsibility but hopefully bigger than
just the financial responsibility
is he's got the human the integrity
the fathering responsibility being a dad
to this little girl